D
OUR POLICE.
>> Jesse: THAT'S RIGHT.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW THE PARTY OF
LAW AND ORDER.
SO WHEN THE SHERIFF'S DEPUTY WAS
MURDERED LAST WEEK IN FLORIDA,
WE EXPECTED TO SEE DEMOCRATS
SPRINT TO THE MICS TO CONDEMN
THIS ATROCIOUS ATTACKS ON COPS.
BUT THERE WAS AN EERIE SILENCE
AND "PRIMETIME" WONDERED WHY.
TURNS OUT THE SHERIFF'S DEPUTY
WAS KILLED BY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT.
NOT JUST ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT AN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT WHO PREVIOUSLY
BEEN DEPORTED AND SNUCK RIGHT
BACK THROUGH JOE BIDEN'S OPEN
BORDER.
WOULDN'T THIS BE A GREAT
POLITICAL OPPORTUNITY FOR
DEMOCRATS TO PUT THEIR MONEY
WHERE THEIR MOUTH IS TO HONOR A
HEROIC POLICE OFFICER AND TOUT
THEIR STRONG BORDER POLICIES?
NOT EVEN THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS?
WHAT DOES VAL DEMINGS HAVE TO
SAY, THE DEMOCRATIC, THE FORMER
ORLANDO POLICE CHIEF RUNNING
AGAINST RUBIO FOR THE SENATE.
A FORMER COLLEAGUE OF HERS WAS
MURDERED BY AN ILLEGAL AND THERE
IS NO RECORD OF HER SAYING
ANYTHING ABOUT THIS.
WE REACHED OUT TO HER OFFICE FOR
A STATEMENT.
SILENCE.
DEMOCRATS WANT THE BORDERS OPEN
BECAUSE THEIR DONORS WANT THE
BORDERS OPEN DEMOCRATS OFF THE
BOOKS TO KEEP PROFITS FLAT AND
PLOW THOSE PROFIT BACK INTO THE
CAMPAIGN WAR CHEST.
THIS KEEPS WAGES DOWN.
BUT SO WHAT?
POLICE DIED, SO WHAT?
PLUS THESE ILLEGALS HAVE BABIES
THAT VOTE 2-1 DEMOCRAT SO
WIN-WIN.
"THE VIEW" SAYS IF YOU ARE
HISPANIC AND YOU DON'T VOTE
DEMOCRAT, THEN YOU AIN'T
HISPANIC.
>> THAT'S WHAT IS SO INTERESTING
TO ME THAT THERE ARE SO MANY
LATINOS THAT VOTE REPUBLICAN
BECAUSE THEY VOTE AGAINST THEIR
OWN SELF-INTEREST.
IF YOU REALLY ARE INTERESTED IN
THESE TYPES OF ISSUES, THEN YOU
ARE A DEMOCRAT.
>> Jesse: SO IF YOU ARE A WHITE
GUY OR WOMAN WHO VOTES
REPUBLICAN YOU ARE A RACIST.
AND IF YOU ARE NOT WHITE AND
VOTE REPUBLICAN, YOU ARE A
RACIAL TRAITOR.
WHAT A WONDERFUL MESSAGE.
BY THE WAY, WHAT'S THE WHITE
HOUSE'S POSITION ON THIS CRIME
WAVE?
WE KNOW THAT DEATHS AND
ROBBERIES ARE UP 20% IN THE
FIRST HALF OF THIS YEAR.
I'M WONDERING IF HE THINKS
AMERICA'S BIG CITIES ARE SAFE.
>> LOOK, THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO
HAS SECURED HISTORIC FUNDING TO
MAKE SURE THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
HAS WHAT IT NEEDS, ESPECIALLY --
AND HE WAS ABLE TO IN THE FACE
OF OPPOSITION FROM REPUBLICANS.
>> Jesse: YEAH, REPUBLICANS WANT
TO DEFUND THE POLICE, EXACTLY.
REPUBLICANS ARE BEATING
DEMOCRATS BY HEFTY 20-POINT
MARGINS ON CRIME AND
IMMIGRATION.
NO ONE IS BUYING THEIR LIES
ANYMORE.
BORDER IS SECURE, THEY LOVE THE
POLICE.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A VERY
LONG TIME AND NO MATTER HOW HARD
THE MEDIA TRIES, THIS COUNTRY
ISN'T BUYING WHAT THEY ARE
SELLING.
DANA LOESCH IS A NATIONALLY
SYNDICATED RADIO HOST AND SHE
JOINS ME NOW.
I CAN'T BELIEVE NO ONE SAID
ANYTHING ABOUT THIS MURDERED LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL IN FLORIDA.
>> I THINK YOU RAISE A REALLY
GOOD POINT, JESSE DEMOCRATS ARE
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT UNTIL IT IS
TIME TO BE FOR.
AND SANCTUARY CITY UNTIL IT
COMES TIME FULFILL SANCTUARY
CITY.
THE THINGS YOU WERE MENTIONING,
I GUESS THAT'S MESSAGING GOING
INTO MIDTERMS TO TAKE EVERYTHING
THEY WERE AGAINST AND RE-PURPOSE
IT AND PRETEND THAT TIME STARTS
RIGHT NOW AND NO ONE CAN USE
THIS TOOL CALLED THE INTERNET
AND GO BACK AND SEE WHERE ALL OF
THESE PEOPLE WERE, ALL OF THESE
YEARS AS NEIGHBORHOODS WERE
BURNING AND PEOPLE WERE GETTING
ASSAULTED AND KILLED?
THEY WERE SCREAMING FOR
DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
IN FACT, THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES WAS SUPPORTING
AND PROMOTING A BAIL FUND FOR
PEOPLE WHO WERE RIOTING IN
MINNEAPOLIS AND MILWAUKEE AND
ELSEWHERE.
NOBODY BELIEVES THESE PEOPLE,
EXCEPT MAYBE ONLY THEIR BASE.
BUT, TO YOUR POINT, WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT, BORDER IS PART OF
THAT BORDER AGENTS AND SECURITY
IS ALL PART OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IF THEY REALLY AND TRULY SUPPORT
LAW ENFORCEMENT SUPPORT ALL
ASPECTS OF THAT AND THAT
INCLUDES, JESSE, AT THE BORDER.
CRESS JESS WHEN YOU HEAR THE
FRENCH WOMAN AS PRESS SECRETARY
EXPLAIN THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
REALLY AGAINST POLICE FUNDING DO
YOU THINK SHE BELIEVES AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE THAT STUPID TO BUY
THAT?
>> I THINK THEY ARE TOO
DESPERATE TO FOCUS GROUP IT.
I THINK THEY ARE INCREDIBLY
DESPERATE RIGHT NOW.
ANYTHING THEY CAN USE TO GET
AMERICA'S EYES OFF THE ECONOMY
AND FOCUS ON ANYTHING ELSE.
THEY WILL TRY IT.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE THROWING ALL
OF THESE OTHER ISSUES THAT
ACTUALLY AREN'T POLLING WELL
WITH THEIR BASE.
THERE WAS A "THE WASHINGTON
POST" POLL OUT THERE SHOWING
LIKE ABORTION AND ALL OF THIS
OTHER STUFF AREN'T POLLS AS WELL
WITH DEMOCRATS IN TERMS OF A
NECESSITY AS AN ISSUE GOING TO
THE POLLS AS DEMOCRATS WOULD
HAVE THOUGHT THAT THEY WOULD.
BUT, NO, I MEAN MAYBE THEY SAY
IT ENOUGH AND THEY WILL BELIEVE
IT.
IT'S KIND OF HARD TO LIE TO
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY AFTER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS.
WE HAVE ALL WITNESSED THE
CARNAGE IN AMERICA'S CITY
STREETS AND WE HAVE, YOU KNOW,
YOU CAN'T LIE TO US.
OUR EYES DON'T LIE.
REST JESS EASY TO LIE ABOUT THE
WEATHER.
ABOUT GLOBAL WARMING, THAT'S
EASY.
BUT WHEN PEOPLE AND YOU ARE
LOOKING AT VIDEO OF PEOPLE
POURING ACROSS AND SHOWING TV
PEOPLE GETTING DEPORTED FROM THE
VINEYARD AND EVERY DAY TURN ON
THE LOCAL NEWS LEADS WITH
SOMEONE GETTING SHOT IN THE BACK
OF THE HEAD.
NO, YOU CAN'T LIE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT THAT.
>> AND REAL QUICK TO YOUR POINT,
WHEN YOU HAVE KARINE JEAN-PIERRE
AS YOU MENTIONED WHEN SHE WAS
STATING SHE TOLD PETER DOOCY
PEOPLE JUST DON'T WALK OVER THE
BORDER.
OH MY GOSH.
YOUR OWN BILL MELUGIN HAS SO
MUCH VIDEO OF THEM LITERALLY
WALKING ACROSS THE BORDER.
>> Jesse: THEY DON'T LIKE BILL
MELUGIN.
>> IT'S TIME FOR THEM TO PUT UP
OR S